summer we did a panel at comic-con you
teased a few different things on screen
you and your brother Anthony as as a
huge battle of the planets person has
there been any more movement on that
we're in what we call the development
phase the way we work at AG the is we do
what we call IP incubation and and it's
a protracted process you know we have to
take something like battle of the
planets put it through our filter find
out what it is that you know or discover
in ourselves what it is that we loved
most about that show growing up
reinterpret it because we're not you
know you know what's not going to be a
direct adaptation of the of the series
it's it's going to be our own story that
we tell surrounding a you know a group
of genetically altered kids who are
involved in a in the space war so that's
that's the approach we take and that
could take months of gestating and
trying to figure out what the the new
mythology is and then we commit that to
a Bible and then from that Bible we do
some artwork as exploration and then
once we have artwork that were inspired
by we then commit that to a script so
we're in the bible phase a battle of the
planets at the moment is that similar to
like for example you were very Susie a
book rim jacket you know magic and stuff
is that where you guys bring jack is in
the script phase it just went in Amazon
for notes so we're waiting to get notes
back from them on that project it's
fantastic script and you know we're
excited about that one of magic as well
as in the script phase animation has a
longer and you know prep period than
most things so it's it's just been a
really a long period of time working
magic